et maintenant place au débat merci
beaucoup d'être resté avec nous on va se
pencher à notre tour sur ce phénomène
d'accaparement de notaire ici en région
et essayer de comprendre les enjeux mais
aussi bien pour nos agriculteurs que
pour nous citoyens quatre invités à mes
côtés pour en parler je vous les
présente
maxime bizarre blondeau bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes prêt
vice-président pardon des jeunes
agriculteurs du loiret derrière son
écran laurent delorme président de la
safer du centre je précise que ça faire
c'est pour société d'aménagement foncier
et d'établissement rural merci beaucoup
à vous d'être à nos côtés aux six autres
invités avec nous en studio jean menu de
la confédération paysanne centre bas
noirs bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être là
et enfin bernard laffitte en visio
administrateur de terre de liens en
centre val de loire mouvement qui
implique les citoyens dans
l'installation d'agriculteurs mais on
aura bien sûr l'occasion d'en reparler
bonsoir à vous également
j'aimerais qu'on commence effectivement
à reparler revenir sur ce phénomène
d'accaparement je dois dire que je
savais que ça existait mais j'aime je
n'imaginais pas qu'il y a qu il avait
une telle ampleur depuis quand est ce
que on peut dire que les terres
françaises sont achetés par des
étrangers
la propriété du foncier agricole a
toujours été un enjeu stratégique
déjà parce que par définition le foncier
agricole est une durée limitée j'allais
dire même une denrée en réduction contre
venus de l'artificialisation des sols et
c'est une denrée stratégique parce
qu'elle permet d'assurer l'alimentation
de la population et des français en
particulier donc la propriété du foncier
agricole a toujours été un enjeu
stratégique et c'est quelque chose qui
s'est énormément développée avec la
mondialisation avec l'augmentation des
échanges notamment des échanges de
matières premières agricoles et ce
phénomène de de l'intérêt et
d'investisseurs étrangers qui cherchent
à posséder du foncier en france parce
qu'il a une haute valeur en termes de
potentiel s'est beaucoup développée à
partir des années 80 l'explosion de la
mondialisation
j'ai lu aussi que la crise de 2008 avait
fait réfléchir pas mal
d'état et de pays ceux qui justement
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de
produire beaucoup chez eux ils se sont
dit
le moment est peut-être venu d'aller
acheter ailleurs est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous ressentez vous
sur vos terres en eure et loir
oui tout à fait alors l'accaparement du
foncier ce n'est pas que le fait des
étrangers c'est aussi le fait
d'agriculteurs bien de chez nous qui
vont arriver qui sert cherche à agrandir
leur ferme qu'elles sont importantes
voire même qu'ils vont acheter du
foncier dans les pays de l'est il ya
même des acteurs beauceron que tu as
acheté 2 au moment de l'ouverture à
l'est quand acheter du foncier de façon
importante dans en roumanie par exemple
et on papa tous les les stratégies
d'accaparement sont pas toutes les mêmes
dans l'exemple de la chine la chine
c'est un pays où il ya 20% de la
population mondiale vit pour cent des
terres arables donc la chine remplir le
bol de riz les chinois c'est quelque
chose de complètement stratégique est
complètement politique donc plutôt que
d'acheter des bons du trésor américain
ils vont acheter le la logistique par
exemple le port du pirée mais ils
viennent aussi acheter de la terre dans
un endroit où on produit de will
production agricole veut dire mais le
plus gros à park un accaparement des
terres
ici c'est pas les étrangers se sont les
acteurs bien de chez nous qui cherche à
grandir de façon importante le fond
c'est gricole parce qu'on va en iran
après par la suite parce que la pac le
permet parce que c'est une mourante
foncière intéressante les droits de
financière intéressante est là on va
reparler de ça justement mais alors en
faisant mes recherches je me suis rendu
compte de ce que nous européens avons
accaparé énormément de terre nous à
l'étranger vous parliez à l'instant des
pays de l'est
ça c'est fait ça se fait encore beaucoup
l'afrique
également il me semble c'était donc un
phénomène qu'on connaissait déjà avant
alors les enfants les européens qui vont
chercher de la terre en afrique
actuellement c'est pas des paysans c'est
plutôt les industriels intéressés par
par l'huile de perles l'huile de palme
entre autres par exemple le soja au
brésil
les européens vont chercher du soja au
brésil vont pas chez le foncier agricole
ils vont chercher la production agricole
pour pouvoir nourrir
enfin la pratique pour les aliments du
bétail mais ils vont pas chercher le
fossé ricol ces deux stratégies
complètement différente un le cap armand
du foncier qui est venue quelque chose
quelque chose qui est mondial il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui s'intéressent
et ajuste type pour mettre dans leur
patrimoine suite aux événements de 2008
mettre dans leur patrimoine une partie
en foncier agricole
c'est quelque chose qui se développe
beaucoup ici en france des boxeurs
étrangers bill gates aux etats unis
c'est un très gros propriétaire foncier
agricole
parce que c'est quelque chose de
stratégique maxime blizzard l'a bien
expliqué peut-être on peut aller poser
la question à laurent delorme la safer
voit passer justement toutes ces
transactions et elle a forcément un avis
là dessus en tout cas est ce que le
centre val de loire est plus touchée que
d'autres régions
est ce que c'est un phénomène très
important chez nous l'accaparement des
terres à vendre avant de parler sur le
sur l'accaparement je voulais juste
redonner le nom de la safer vous avez
expliqué les la salle fermée
ouais là voilà elle a été elle a été
créée a été créée dans les années dans
les années 1960 par l'état parce que
l'état a voulu a voulu une volonté de
l'état pour pour accompagner les
agriculteurs et en particulier les
jeunes pour les qu'ils puissent
s'installer et donc les affaires sont
créés bon ça a permis de réguler ça
permet de révéler également le foncier
et tout ça à l'intérieur de cette
affaire on a un grand nombre de
participants ceux qui sont les syndicats
agricoles
les chambres d'agriculture les les
collectivités ainsi que de les banques
les assurances et tous les syndicats
autre que ce que je vais le site et oui
vous voulez dire que vous n'êtes pas un
organisme comme moi vous êtes ancré dans
le territoire et qu'il ya plein de vos
côtés et finalement et tout ça et tout
ça sous le contrôle de l'état
donc ça quand même venez pas et donc
tout ça c'est pour ça que le foncier le
foncier c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
d'accord que tout le monde veut du
foncier mais c'est déjà dans les années
60 il ya des grosses exploitations
commencé à se créer
et donc pas ce que par les safer on a pu
être limitée et alors pour en revenir à
ma question est ce qu'on a le sentiment
que le centre val de loire est très
convoité parce qu'on a parlé dans le
documentaire qu'on ait vu juste avant on
a parlé du béret on a parlé de l'allier
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé d'autres
territoires est ce que le nôtre il est
particulièrement intéressant pour les
investisseurs étrangers est ce qu'ils
sont très présents alors il est
certainement plus peut-être plus
intéressant que les autres jeux pas sûr
mais mais on avait quand même dans des
régions du centre val de loire tels que
le berry ou holeindre où on a on a des
des terres qui sont ne sont pas
régulières comme la beauce ou que dans
le nord de la région oui et et donc ses
terres où les agriculteurs ont quand
même des difficultés en difficulté ou
pour poursuivre leurs activités
et quand on a des des investisseurs
comme les chinois bon pour moi ils sont
les dix bon on va trouver on va trouver
votre agriculteurs qui veulent vendre
leurs terres et et qui vont permettre le
coup de continuer ou bien de prendre
leur retraite parce qu'il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas forcément des remplaçants pour
eux sur leur exploitation d'accord
maxim's à vous pensez pas que c'est
parce qu'on a une qualité de sol où on a
des zones particulièrement intéressante
en terme de culture dans notre région de
manière générale la france la production
agricole française extrêmement réputé à
l'international il n'y a qu'en france où
l'on tape sur les productions agricoles
françaises dès qu'on sort de la france
comme les autres pays d'europe ou du
monde
nous avons tout le territoire français
une réputation hors norme
et comme le disait laurent les
investisseurs y voient les opportunités
et on a dans la région et notamment dans
le sud de la région
ce qu'on appelle la zone intermédiaire
c'est des zones qui aujourd'hui sont
dans une certaine impasse économiques et
agronomiques qui font que la viabilité
des exploitations est de moins en moins
présente
donc il ya de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs qui lorsqu'on leur
propose un chèque pour soi prendre leur
retraite soit arrêtée avant leur
retraite ils sont sensibles parce que
faute de gagner de revenus il est
toujours tentant de céder à l'appel
purement pécunier que peuvent proposer
des investisseurs étrangers
je me sens plus que c'est vraiment une
une question d'opportunité ou deux par
une difficulté agronomiques et
économiques au sud de la région
les investisseurs se concentrent là où
il ya du foncier qui peut
potentiellement se libérer en quantité
et est ce que en termes de prix le
centre-ville de l'or on considère que
les terres sont plus abordables ont pris
keller quand on parle de prix il faut
savoir les cours se compare par rapport
au reste de l'europe le français gricole
en france il n'est pas très cher car ce
qu'il est protégé par le statut du
fermage qui a permis de limiter le coût
du foncier agricole et c'est vrai que
dès lors que des investisseurs étrangers
et puis que l'accaparement des terres
des paysans parce que les principales
accapare de terre ce sont des
agriculteurs des enfants qui sont
presque devenus maintenant les agri
managers sont eux les principaux
personnes qui font monter les prix
également un jeu dire il ya des secteurs
par exemple en beauce où l'irrigation
est possible et où il ya des terres qui
sont tout à fait adaptées pour cultiver
des pommes de terre ou le prix des
terres s'envole dans une des mesures
extraordinaires
ce qui n'est pas acceptable de dire donc
par rapport à ça il ya absolument besoin
de réguler l'accès au foncier pour
permettre l'installation de nouveaux
agriculteurs on y reviendra dans le
débat bien sûr mais c'est quelque chose
de très important de colorer que le
foncier soit régulée alors dans les
outils de régulation il ya effectivement
la safer mais il ya aussi d'autres
outils qui peuvent pas réduire ce
affaire il ya ce qu'on appelle le
contrôle des structures
oui il ya également la pac la politique
agricole commune aujourd'hui qui verse
des aides à la surface
donc c'est très tentant pour les acteurs
d'aller chercher davantage de surface
pour aller chercher davantage de prix
mis d'accord si on s'en tient on va
parler ensuite des deux des
investisseurs français qui investit sur
nos terres mais si on parle des
investisseurs étrangers qu'est ce qu'ils
viennent chercher ils viennent cultiver
pour exporter systématiquement où est-ce
qu'ils viennent au silva pour avoir ces
aides de la pac est possible et ce
qu'ils ont le droit la réalité c'est
qu'il est en l'occurrence les chinois
dans l'indre ils ont couru après un
mirage
ils se sont dit qu'ils allaient pouvoir
faire en france ce qu'ils ont fait dans
d'autres pays du monde
ouais sauf que en france par le contexte
réglementaire qui a été développée
depuis les années 60 par la safer par le
contrôle des structures le statut du
fermage
on sait pas le far west le monde
agricole français
c'est quand même extrêmement réglementé
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
mais c'est quand même extrêmement
innovante et mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que quand on parle de fonds
6 et d'acquisition par des sociétés
étrangères du fond ces français là il
n'y a plus beaucoup
il ya des trous dans la raquette
réglementaire c'est une certitude mais
en ce qui concerne de l'usaj du foncier
c'est à dire l'exploité pas seulement de
l'acheter à un moment donné ça sert pas
à grand-chose d'acheter du foncier à
l'instant t
ce qui est intéressant c'est de le
mettre en valeur mais ils sont
confrontés au monde agricole français
qui est extrêmement structurée avec une
logistique qui est mutualisé entre
l'ensemble des agriculteurs et ils n'ont
pas eu l'opportunité de créer leur
propre réseau logistique qu'il aurait
permis de produire en france pour
importer des denrées directement chez
eux sans passer par nos canaux de de
concentration et de distribution
habituel donc en fin de compte ils ont
ils ont cherché un mirage ils n'ont pas
trouvé et qu'ils ne trouveront jamais
tant que nous veillerons à ce que le
monde agricole et le monde politique
travailler ensemble à préserver
l'intérêt souveraineté de la
souveraineté alimentaire française
donc vous avez l'impression que ça aide
pour le monde sait comment ça elle
limite un petit peu louette
il faut être extrêmement vigilant il
faut boucher les trous dans la raquette
réglementaires pour que plus jamais des
investisseurs étrangers puissent acheter
des terres sans avoir notre accord peut
s'entendre au cas par cas d'accepter des
capitaux étrangers mais il faut que ce
soit soumis à l'accord de l'état des
pouvoirs publics
là il ya eu un trou dans la raclette
raquette pardon il ya aujourd'hui des
initiatives parlementaires qui sont en
cours pour justement résorber ce
problème là et après il faut
s'intéresser aux autres problématique du
foncier parce que c'est très facile de
mettre en avant les capitaux étrangers
mais c'est la phase émergée de l'iceberg
la problématique de l'agrandissement
excessif des exploitations il concerne
en fin de compte beaucoup plus de
territoire est beaucoup plus de faire
c'est un peu ce que vous disiez
vous écoute à contenir en temps de
bernard l les as les achats étrangers
sont très faibles en région centre
j'étais très bien effectivement il ya eu
là on a mis beaucoup de spots sur les
chinois qu'elle a acheté d'autres cartes
dans l'un des six qui sont je crois dans
la ligne pendant ces énormes mais il ya
que ça comme un jeu comme à l'étranger
les agriculteurs de la région centre
comptait acheter deux latéraux rhmani
s'est beaucoup plus important que ça je
veux dire donc il faut être modeste
les agents russes c'est pas grand chose
effectivement pour pour pour la chine
qui a besoin de nourrir tous et où toute
sa population je veux dire compte tenu
de l'excédent budgétaire qu'ils ont
acheté de la terre en un jour sans que
c'était une autre studio et on a envie
de vous vouliez réagir à nos échanges
justement que we have et je reviens au
tout début
concernant la la présentation par la
safer
c'est à dire que la safer a été créé
tout de suite après la guerre quand même
et quand même l'idée il le semble
c'était que le foncier n'était pas une
marchandise et que quand on a les lois
après la guerre ont voulu sortir quand
même un peu les terres agricoles de la
marchandisation
voilà c'est quand même un pourrait
considérer la terre comme un bien commun
comme
comme l'eau ou l'air voilà donc c'est
une première chose qu'elle voulait
peut-être équipiers donc
donc voilà le foncier c'est quand même
autre chose ce n'est pas une marchandise
et si non en fait je rejoins plutôt
comment dire moi je suis dans l'est du
loiret je reçois shield maintenant c'est
à dire que effectivement c'est pas
tellement les investisseurs étrangers
qui achètent de la terre encore chez
nous tu es beaucoup plus des
agriculteurs français des beaucerons des
gens du nord et idra c'est à dire que
effectivement infiniband 3 ha ha ha ha
chez eux ils achètent 3 ha chez nous et
avec l'effet pervers effectivement
d'agrandissement c'est à dire que ils
ont quand même leur siège d'exploitation
chez eux ils vont acheter 100 200 300
hectares par chez nous et du coup ils
vont défendre deux fois par an avec un
engin agricole des crocs des gros
tracteur pour cultiver et après ils
repartent et ils appauvrissent
énormément note qu'en dira notre notre
territoire
je veux dire il appauvrit finalement je
vois un e mail à tcc c'est moi je suis
je m'inscris totalement en faux
la terre n'est pas un bien commun c'est
un enjeu stratégique et c'est pour ça
que les safer ont été créés pour
réglementer un marché qui existait avant
et qui continue d'exister aujourd'hui et
je précise que c'est un outil qu'on a
nous en france mais qui n'existe pas
payés d'europe donc on s'est presque 1,1
à tous ces de plus c'est je termine
s'ils voulaient bien la terre n'est pas
un bien commun c'est un enjeu
stratégique national pour assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire pour choisir
notre modèle agricole aussi avec les
contraintes sociétales qu'on souhaite y
apporter
mais l'idée de recréer des kolkhozes qui
serait un bien commun est aberrante et
ne correspond pas à la nécessité
d'innover ce qu'il ya derrière
derrière cette notion bien gentil de
bien commun c'est mutualiser ses
formidables
cc je termine le l'agriculture française
aujourd'hui c'est un modèle que tous
nous partageons je pense dans ce débat
elle est basée sur une agriculture à
taille humaine avec la t25 ya consensus
avec des exploitations de taille
raisonnable avec
un agriculteur ou un groupement de
quelques agriculteurs et un ou deux
salariés grosso modo donc des
exploitations dans notre région allez on
va dire de moins de 250 ha si on prend
un chiffre voire des exploitations à
taille humaine
on est le seul pays au monde à tenir à
ce modèle dans les autres pays d'europe
eux leur modèle c'est de produire nous
on veut produire mais produire suivant
un modèle social et sociétal
d'exploitation à taille humaine et ça
suppose d'avoir des agriculteurs qui
souhaitent des chefs d'entreprise qui
soit responsable de leur entreprise et
donc on ne peut pas être sur quelque
chose de bien commun où on aurait comme
ça des citoyens qui viendra à tour de
rôle tenir le rôle de chef
d'exploitation
non il faut des entrepreneurs agricoles
sur des exploitations de taille
raisonnable
effectivement il faut s'attendre dans
l'école mais qu en commun dans la fidh
parle de biens communs pour la terre
vient c'est pas dans le sens de ses
ports pour dénier le droit de propriété
joueurs ont respecté dans le monde droit
de priorité par contre l'usagé du bien
et ricol c'est un bien commun rien parce
que l'usagé agricole c'est pour
l'alimentation déjà on veut dire maison
que dans ces cas là il faut que les une
régulation importante sur l'usagé biens
agricoles n'est pas acceptable que des
propriétaires s'accapare de plus en plus
du fonds serricole pour mettre en valeur
des fois au travers de deux panneaux
photos en ligne de méthanisation ou pour
s'accaparer de la rendre qu'elle a pas
que je dire en créant très peu de
richesse est méritoire en particulier
dans la zone intermédiaire le dire de
plus en plus on voit une culture végétal
se développer un gros on cultive du
colza du blé de l'orge sacre est très
peu de richesse se dire pour les paysans
qui qui me mettre en valeur ces
techniques là je veux dire c'est un
système qui crée très peu de richesse où
il ya très peu d'actifs dire qu'il
ramasse beaucoup d'argent de primes pac
puisque les primes pas qu'ils savent
très bien les utiliser à ce niveau là
sur le territoire on l'a bien vu dans le
film cela conduit à un espèce de
déclassement social du territoire on
voit de fer membres donné ça c'est pas
que c'est à dire on pourrait tout à fait
concevoir une production agricole
cent deux cents ans sans intervenir sur
droit de propriété des gens mais on
pourra voir un usage bien agricoles qui
favorisent des paysans nombreux avec une
alimentation très diversifié avec des
productions très diversifié avec une
biodiversité resterait aujourd'hui
l'agrandissement sans fin ricol conduit
à à faire payer à l'environnement
impact très for lire ça dégrade la
qualité des eaux
ils vont en partie l'argent santé tant
en zone nitrates - parce que la qualité
des eaux se dégradent due à un modèle
d'agricole qui n'est plus acceptable
aujourd'hui que l'associé ne veut plus
dire il faut être vos organisations
syndicales défendre ce modèle agricole
qui quand même présente de nombreuses
limites qui est très fragile
les organisations gens représentent
qu'une aujourd'hui à récurer les jeunes
agriculteurs le slogan photo juste aux
communes aux élections vous êtes sur le
même modèle du slogan des jeunes
agriculteurs cd ferme pas des firmes
donc on est les premiers à défendre des
installations nombreuses sources des
exploitations à taille humaine
si on ne veut pas de firmes et des
fermes dont la solution on serait quand
même qu'on légifère autour d'eux alors
je reviens sur l'accaparement qu'on
légifère là dessus il ya des lois qui
ont commencé à pointer le bout de leur
nez
emmanuel macron avait promis une loi sur
le fond c est qui
ne cesse d'être reporté on parle
peut-être de la sortir lors d'un
prochain futur mandat éventuellement
pourquoi on légifère pas pourquoi on
encadre pas tout ça alors qu'on a cet
outil la safer et pourquoi pourquoi ne
fait pas on a légiféré par le passé
jeudi il ya eu des textes qui ont été
retoqués par le conseil communal parce
que c est la liberté entreprendre qui
mangent à dire donc les textes otero
toqué mais il ya des lois qui sont enfin
il ya quand même des on en voit dans
l'oeil un député qui porte dominique
potier wiki qui porte une loi foncière
qu'il veut donner aux safer des moyens
d'intervenir sur le marché du foncier
parce que la safer enfin lors de le dire
beaucoup mieux que moi je n'interviens
conditions du marché jeudi
il représente pas énormément je veux
dire et si on leur donne pas les moyens
d'intervenir parce que aujourd'hui ce
que l'on voit bien c'est le processus
d'accaparement des terres se fait via
des montages sociétaires et les chinois
avait utilisé cette technique là pour
acheter du foncier et la safer n'a pas
pu intervenir mais aussi de nombreux
agriculteurs
ici en région centre qui utilisent des
techniques de montage de sociétés pour
pouvoir s'accaparer les terres et dans
ces cas là la safer ne peut pas
intervenir
ils sont canadiens les étrangers le font
pourquoi pas moi non non non non
l'argument c'est pas soulagé l'argument
c'est que les électeurs c'est d'abord et
avant tout des des des agents
économiques dire dès lors que la loi
leur permet de via des montages
d'accueillir davantage de foncier et que
dès lors que la politique agricole
commune ne vais pas de limite à ça je
veux dire donc c'est très intéressant
d'aller sac après sans arrêt du foncier
d'accord bernard ft vous voulez réagir
et après il faut quand même qu'on parle
justement de cet accaparement et de ses
conséquences sur l'agrandissement des
fermiers du coup le problème pour les
jeunes de s'installer mais je vous
écoute d'abord oui alors c'est pas
facile d'intervenir en visio juste pour
préciser que effectivement bien sûr moi
quand j'ai parlé comme un film no a bien
bien situer les choses je parlais pas
comment dire je disais que la terre mais
était ne pouvait pas être considérée
comme une marchandise 4 à la guerre
c'était quand l'esprit un donc
qui était après la guerre j'ai dit que
ça pouvait s'apparenter c'est plus une
utilisation commune et il n'est pas
question bien sûr de créer des kolkhozes
a absolument pas la preuve cette terre
de liens quand même fait appel à
l'épargné citoyenne achète achètent des
terres et mobilisent les citoyens pour
pour acheter des terres ils deviennent
actionnaires
donc on n'est pas du tout terre de liens
n'est pas du tout contre la propriété
privée est juste la dernière chose
peut-être que je veux ouvrir celle que
effectivement moi ce que je vois autour
de chez moi
en région centre dans le loiret fait que
les chinois
effectivement ils ne sont pas trop
entrer dans le marché
c'est beaucoup plus d'autres
agriculteurs en fait qui s'accaparent
qui achètent des terres pour différentes
raisons et surtout pour toucher les
primes pac pour que l'effet pervers des
chinois c'est qu'ils ont fait augmenter
les prix
et moi j'ai plein de voisins qui me dit
j'ai je pars à la retraite j'ai des
paravents et bien j'attends que les
chinois bien acheter parce que les
chinois ils achètent il faut il y à deux
fois plus cher et du coup ils ont comme
on dit ils ont déstabilisé le marché
exactement et du coup bah je dirais que
les premiers touchés sont ceux qui
veulent s'installer
est-ce que vous il y en a beaucoup de
jeunes agriculteurs quand vous donnez
moi je veux m'installer dans le secteur
où je suis les prix c'est on peut pas
s'aligner c'est pas possible ça arrive
souvent ça on central de lens ça arrive
très souvent et malheureusement ça va
arriver encore plus souvent demain je
donne deux chiffres il ya vingt-deux
mille agriculteurs aujourd'hui en région
centre
en un peu plus de dix mille qui vont
prendre leur retraite d'ici 2026
c'est un défi énorme la relève agricole
a organisé est astronomique et c'est dix
mille exploitations reprendre à faire
les transmettre il va falloir que les
jeunes qui vont reprendre ces
exploitations et les moyens de le
reprendre
ce qu'on peut avoir des outils pour
empêcher des transactions faut tel que
nous proposions une alternative
on peut pas juste bloquer le marché il
faut bien avoir une alternative à
proposer à un acquérir un acquéreur
étranger ou un agriculteur déjà en place
qui vous
s'agrandir excessivement et on a besoin
d'outils de portage du foncier c'est à
dire du de capitaux extérieurs qui
accompagne les jeunes lorsqu'ils
souhaitent s'installer
c'est ce que fait terre de liens c'est
ce que est en train de travailler
la safer c'est ce que font aussi
quelques apporteurs de capitaux privés
français il y en a aujourd'hui des
personnes qui veulent placer une partie
de leur épargne en achetant du foncier
mais sans aucune velléité de l'exploiter
donc qui accompagne les jeunes pour pour
s'installer mais ont il faut qu'on soit
beaucoup plus efficace l'ampleur c'est
pas d'accompagner dix ou quinze
exploitant par an et par département
c'est d'avoir un dispositif massif y
compris avec de l'argent public de mon
point de vue pour porter le foncier et
permettre aux jeunes de reprendre le
support de leurs activités et ce qui
fait en fin de compte l'avis de leur
exploitation et le potentiel de leur
carrière d'agriculteur laurent delorme
en tant que président de la safer
j'imagine que vous avez cette
problématique là en tête
vous aussi les jeunes vous sollicite
beaucoup en vous disant aidez nous
trouver une solution et des noix nous
installer pour poursuivre ce que je
viens de dire
maxime en effet on a des jeunes qui
veulent qui veulent s'installer
heureusement encore parce que y'en a pas
non plus y en a pas non plus à l'appel
comme on peut dire c'est je pense que
c'est une exploitation sur trois qui est
repris par aujourd'hui par un jeune donc
vous voyez un peu le
le dga donc pour mille pour motiver les
jeunes il faut il faut trouver des
solutions communes expliqué maxime et
ses solutions on essaye donc on essaye
s'affaire donc là on va on a un
partenariat avec avec eux avec le créa
école que paul cité qui va aider et d
apporter justement pour acheter ce
foncier pendant pendant cinq ou dix ans
afin que le jeune puisse un peu se
renflouer pour pouvoir au bout de ses 10
ans à acheter du foncier qu'on aura
porté pendant dix ans entre la safer et
c'est donc mais bon ça cette semaine est
une chose mais ça fait baisser sa
boutique pour motiver pour motiver les
jeunes ccc aujourd'hui moi je vois je
vois juste à côté de chez moi
aujourd'hui une exploitation de 150
hectares
les enfants n'en veulent pas et pourtant
dans la beauce et du potentiel de la
rose d'irrigation et les enfants ils en
veulent pas alors qu'il pourrait y avoir
donc c'est pour ça que l'on fait on
essaye de trouver des solutions on
essaye d'aider les jeunes mais au bout
on a on a beaucoup de difficulté même si
si on fait tout pour pour arriver à
aboutir à l'installation et vous avez
vous aussi chez mado que les jeunes ne
sont pas forcément pourquoi si si les
jeunes sont intéressés pour reprendre
parce que vous et dans les lycées
agricoles il ya plein de jeunes qui
étaient au moins en moins il ya
énormément de jeunes dans les lycées
agricoles de moins en moins région
centre et bien d'autres écoles qui
ferment tous les ans dans notre région
on français encore beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de jeunes dans les lycées
agricoles qui voudraient s'installer
jeudi est la principale difficulté c'est
l'axé foncé mais c'est aussi l'absence
de revenus aussi qui touchent aussi bien
qu'aujourd'hui quand du foncier agricole
se libère il ya davantage de gens qui
sont là pour s'agrandir que de jeunes
pour cette faute de revenus via et et la
pac ne courage pas du tout ça je veux
dire pourquoi pour avoir un
renouvellement important des générations
et maxime bizarre elle explique très
bien qu'il ya énormément de fonds saisis
vestes et des règles pour ça il faudrait
qu'une politique le veuille vraiment je
veux dire et dans les attendus de la
prochaine pac c'est bien il est bien
bien acté le renouvellement des
générations je veux dire donc ça c'est
absolument indispensable
il n'y a pas que le foncier qui une
politique foncière qui sera suffisante
il faut être une pac agricole qui est
flèche des aides vers les actifs et
aussi enfin quelque chose que porte très
fort la crèche à bezannes une aide aux
petites fermes pour pour les transmettre
comme plus facile à transmettre une
petite ferme à condition qu'ils aient du
rendu parce qu'il faut pas beaucoup
moins de capital
il reprend une petite ferme que panneaux
muraux de ferme de 150 hectares où les
dasri faudrait il faut redonner ses
ailes en tout cas les lélés qu'elles
soient plus généreuses pour les jeunes
pour les petits terme il pour chaouchi
après beaucoup de revenir c'est pas
d'être généreux dire c'est d'être plus
équitable veut dire sur une ferme de son
secteur l'un de revenus c'est cent mille
euros le dire sur une petite femme qui
fait que du maraîchage c'est moins de
1000 euros dire dès lors qu'on fléchir
et les aides non pas en fonction de la
surface mais en fonction et des actifs
qu'ils travailleraient
réellement je dire là on pourrait mettre
en place une autre dynamique
on pourrait trouver du revenu dans des
petites fermes veut dire aujourd'hui sur
la région je suis en france 50% des
fruits et légumes viennent de l'étranger
on pourrait tout à fait produire ici en
région centre dans la vallée de la loi
et notamment de fruits et légumes jeudi
dans ce cas là il faudrait une politique
agricole qui accompagne ça il faudrait
également aussi une fiscalité agricole
en matière de transmission qui soit plus
plus plus plus percutante pour pouvoir
favoriser davantage de renouvellement de
génération aujourd'hui les personnes qui
partent à la retraite ils ont une
retraite à riscle qui est quand même
relativement ridicule qui va être un peu
revalorisés dont on les admire mais qui
serait qu'ils resteraient véhicule donc
les gens qui quittent après cyril
cherche à valoriser leurs biens au mieux
il ya dans ces cas là les jeunes qui
s'installent qui n'ont pas de capital
et bien c'est une difficulté énorme pour
eux je dire et dans ces cas là on voit
souvent des gens qui vont les serbes
malheureusement vers l'agrandissement
alors qu'on alors que vous pouvez
renouveler de façon importante que l'on
aurait nécessité de renouveler de façon
importante et pour cela il faut changer
mais agricole en région sans lui dire il
faut sans doute aller vers une pression
plus diversifiée le dire est davantage
la reprise des fermes
vous partagez cet avis mais je sais
quand on a préparé l'émission vous me
disiez plus on agrandit monde diversifié
du coup on appauvrit
c'est un fait c'est pas ressenti plus
les exploitations sont grandes plus la
valeur ajoutée créée à l'hectare est
faible parce que nécessairement plus
exploitations sont grandes plus on
simplifie le système de l'exploitation
plus on réduit le nombre d'ateliers
d'élevage le nombre de cultures sur
l'exploitation pour pouvoir supporter la
charge de travail sans embaucher deux
personnes supplémentaires on pourrait se
dire si on est grand on peut embaucher
des gens en plus concrètement pour vous
deux ferme 200 hectares accords vont
générer deux fois plus de chiffre
d'affaires qu'une ferme de 200 ha oui
c'est la réalité dans la région centre
c'est quand on a des petites
exploitations on va voir plus de culture
différente on va souvent avoir un
atelier d'élevage à côté et donc on va
générer plus de valeur ajoutée pour soi
mais aussi pour le territoire qui nous
entoure pour le vétérinaire pour le
concessionnaire de matériel agricole
pour la boutique de produits produits
locaux qui va être dans le village pour
ces enfants qui vont à l'école du
village donc l'enjeu il est pas
seulement agricoles il est de la vie
économique et sociale qu'apportent les
exploitations dans ces territoires mais
j'aime autant vous tenez tous le même
discours alors pourquoi ça se fait pas
mais peut-être que cette course à la
part des exploitations sur le fait de
diversifier sur le fait d'avoir des
fermes plus petit on valorise mieux on
embauche
enfin vous êtes d'accord là dessus
pourquoi ça se fait parce que ya deux
candidats il ya deux éléments différents
il ya déjà un contexte économique qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a une grande
partie des exploitations qui sont en
difficulté dans l'est grosso modo 10
mille exploitations qui vont être à
transmettre chiffres msa y en a dix
mille qui sont en grande difficulté
économique
et c'est pas simple de transmettre à
nous y travaillent quand une fois à la
retraite on va avoir 600 ou 700 euros de
retraite à partir du 1er septembre le
ministre de l'agriculture se félicite
qu'on aura droit à 80% du smic
après 45 ans de labeur en agriculture je
pas sûr qu'il faille s'en féliciter donc
non seulement ils ont peu dépeindre dans
leurs exploitations récupérer au moment
de leur transmission et en plus derrière
ils vont avoir une retraite ridicule et
ça c'est un vrai enjeu que de faire en
sorte que lorsqu'un agriculteur prend sa
retraite il ya une retraite décente
qu'il ait pas de remords à prendre sa
retraite
et derrière il ya une question de
politique publique de politique agricole
commune notamment où on est passé en
désaccord que s'agit a travaillé depuis
très longtemps sur l'actif agricole
c'est l'idée d'y dire que les dbz
couplet les aides à l'hectare
les aides découplées à l'hectare n'ont
pas beaucoup de sens en fin de compte
parce qu'on ne valorise pas celui qui va
justement aller chercher de la valeur
ajoutée aller chercher du circuit court
aller chercher des produits diversifiés
et que tant qu'on est dans un système on
laisse aux agriculteurs le choix de leur
production de le choix de
commercialisation autant être sur une
aide entre guillemets forfaitaire à
l'actif c'est à dire j'ai une ferme et
ben l'europe ma compagne et après juge à
moi de choisir mes productions et pour
donner un chiffre pour dire que c'est
possible de faire ça c'est que au niveau
national en france il ya 12 % des
bénéficiaires pac qui représente un peu
plus de 10% du budget pacte national qui
ont plus de 67 ans on en a 5 % ont plus
de 75 ans et ça doit interroger parce
que il y en a quelques-uns dans ceux là
qui sont toujours agriculteurs dans les
faits mais l'immense majorité d'entre
eux
sont plus aérées culture ils font faire
leur ferme voisins et je pense que il
faut avoir des hommes et des femmes
politiques et j'espère que ce sera le
cas du musée agriculture qui ait le
courage de dire la politique agricole
commune
c'est de l'argent public c'est là pour
orienter le modèle agricole en fonction
des attentes de la société et que à
compter de la prochaine pac à compter du
1er janvier 2023 on cible l'argent
public est colossal
c'est énorme c'est nécessaire on le site
vers ceux qui font l'agriculture
d'aujourd'hui et de demain donc vers les
agriculteurs de moins de 67 ans et vers
l'accompagnement aux jeunes qui
souhaitent devenir agriculteur il ya
bernard laffitte qui veut intervenir
parce que forcément lui avec tard
devenir j'imagine qu'ils en croise pas
mal des jeunes agriculteurs
et qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise il trouve
pas il n'y arrive pas c'est trop cher ou
c'est trop grand alors les jeunes qu'on
parle des jeunes ou les moins jeunes
d'ailleurs qu'ils viennent voir
effectivement eu le
ils disent pas forcément que c'est trop
cher d'ailleurs soit ils disent que
c'est trop cher effectivement ils ont
pas les moyens d'acheter à retracer une
chose ils peuvent dire aussi que il
préfère mettre leur argent dans une
petite production plutôt que dans la
terre 1 et investir je sais pas sûr du
sur des tracteurs sur sur du bétail ou
autre chose comme ça et ils ont aussi en
règle générale du mal à trouver du
foncier
alors ça dépend des projets parce que
terre de lien on peut aussi bien sur des
projets sur 1 ha de maraîchage comme des
projets de grande culture sur son trente
hectares il ya aucun problème
c'est très très large mais c'est vrai
que souvent on rencontre des jeunes qui
veulent s'installer en maraîchage qui
chefs de trois états et qu'il ne les
trouve pas assez réelle alors qu'à côté
il ya des fermes de 60 états qui se
vendent donc là il ya ce problème là par
contre moi je voulais revenir sur autre
chose peut-être c'est que et ben déjà
dans fait on en trouve des jeunes qui
ont des on en trouve alors on les trouve
pas forcément ce dans les lycées
agricoles
il y en a qui trouvent dans les lycées
agricoles cbre r&d fils d'exploitation
d'exploitants 1
mais on trouve aussi beaucoup alors ce
qu'on appelle des hors cadres familiaux
n'est ce pas uniquement nous les gens
qu'on installe en règle générale ce sont
des gens qui soit son issue déjà du
monde agricole mais qui sont allés
travailler autre part qui ont eu un
autre emploi et qui reviennent à la
ferme familiale sont b où on peut aussi
beaucoup des gens qui on travaillait
autre part souvent qu'on était cadre ou
autre chose et qui apprend 35 ans en
fait on envie de changer depuis ont
envie de gang
on ne marque pas la ville voir on fait
même des peurs la route parce que
c'était des cadres comment dire des
cadres qui étaient
je travaille énormément et du coup ils
ont fait un choix de vie et le gros
avantage c'est que comme ils ont fait un
choix de vie nous on leur dit attention
le monde agricole vous n'allez pas faire
5h04 70 heures par semaine c'est pas du
tout la même chose et mais ça ils en
sont conscients et ils ont vraiment
réfléchi à ça et on trouve vraiment moi
le moi je trouve on trouve des jeunes et
le gros avantage est que je trouve qu
enfin quand on voit les jeunes qui
s'installent partir devient par exemple
moi je peux vous citer plein d'exemples
c'est que souvent sur une sphère où et
c'est là on ne peut avoir de l'espoir
c'est que sur une ferme où il y avait
par exemple une ferme de 60 hectares qui
appartenait à un agriculteur qu'on avait
120 donc j'ai uniquement lui il est
chouette et la moitié comme un bon là
c'est la moitié d'accord et d'un nous on
va installer trois jeunes sur des
productions différents avec des salariés
c'est à dire que très souvent dans nos
fermes carte de lien donc en rachète une
sphère où il y avait un exploitant eh
ben on va installer deux trois voire
quatre 4 ou moins jeunes et d'une grande
ferme vous allez faire trempette et
tombe en parler dans l'ensemble c'est
quand même ce qui est annoncé également
dans ce documentaire mieux vaut trois
petites fermes qu'une seule grande
d'abord je voudrais qu'on re qu'on se
replonge dans un sujet d'archivés qu'on
a retrouvée et justement qui est évoqué
ce problème des départs à la retraite et
des jeunes comment on fait pour que ceux
qui partent et ceux qui veulent
s'installer se rencontrent et ben il ya
quelque chose qui s'appelle le farm
dating
oui oui vous avez bien entendu on
connaissait le speed dating le job
dating
voilà le forme dating ici on n'est pas
là pour trouver l'amour mais bien un
projet de vie autour de l'agriculture un
métier passion qui souffre d'une moyenne
d'âge élevée plus de 50 % des
exploitants ont plus de 50 ans et chaque
année ils sont 150 à partir à la
retraite
la chambre de l'agriculture de l'indre
qui a eu cette idée de rencontres tire
la sonnette d'alarmé
le leitmotiv c'est renouveler les
générations aujourd'hui deux exploitants
et demi alors le
c'est difficile de le matérialiser
partent en retraite quand tu as une
personne s'installe donc sur les
territoires il faut absolument mettre
tout en oeuvre pour que pour inverser
ces chiffres ou au moins les contenir
top chrono les agriculteurs ont sept
minutes pas une de plus pour faire
connaissance et voir si leurs objectifs
peuvent être compatibles
bref voir si ça match parce que j'ai
envie d'aller danser dans une voie là
c'est toujours une bonne expérience et
je pensais pour le professionnel aussi
que cherche des jeunes donc en envoyant
sa doit toujours se comporter dans
l'esprit c'était un jeune je serais
content parce que ce soit repris par un
jeune qui est passionné dans l'élevage
on y passe du temps donc en émoi au delà
de
de transmettre quelque chose de
financière je transmette une passion
quand même
l'élevage c'est une passion mais ce
secteur d'activité souffrent aussi d' a
priori une candidate de 20 ans s'est vu
refuser une exploitation non pas pour
son jeune âge mais bien parce que
c'était une femme je pensais que les
gens il avait évolué un petit peu et en
fin de compte les gens ils sont toujours
dans une ferme c'est un homme qui est
capable de faire le travail alors que
l'on pas du tout équipés comme mon
équipe aujourd'hui même une femme elle
est capable de faire le travail qui est
à faire dans une ferme
ce rendez vous est un succès si bien
qu'une deuxième session aura lieu en
novembre prochain pour participer il
faut s'inscrire auprès de la chambre
d'agriculture de l'indre alors je crois
que les gia fonsat également finalement
donc c'est quelque chose que ça date
d'il ya quelques années ça a dû marcher
vous vous êtes dit ce n'est pas une
mauvaise idée on va les chercher
laurent delorme à la safer mais vous
voulez réagir déjà là dessus simplement
pour confirmer les propos on a de plus
en plus de jeunes non issus du milieu
agricole qui viennent s'investir dans
nos métiers et ça apporte énormément de
fraîcheur au monde agricole une vision
c'est quelque chose que vous voyez que
beaucoup de bienveillance ou énormément
parce que des jeunes qui sont pas issus
d'une famille d'agriculteurs apporte une
vision beaucoup plus proche des attentes
sociétales
parce que des gens qui ont déjà eu un
parcours dans l'entreprise et qui sont
en reconversion apporte des compétences
en termes de management de
commercialisation de mise en circuit
court qui sont extraordinaires
un point de vigilance tout de même sur
le va falloir bosser 70 heures je pense
qu'il est important qu'on porte un
message de dire que oui aujourd'hui tous
les agriculteurs ne vivent pas bien de
leur métier c'est la réalité ce serait
aberrant de le nier mais qu' il est
possible par les outils qui existent par
les opportunités qui existent sur les
marchés de s'installer en agriculture et
de vivre correctement de son métier la
plupart des jeunes qui s'installent
aujourd'hui dans notre région mais
partout en france arrive raisonnablement
bien à se libérer du temps dans une vie
sociale tout en se dégageant un revenu
décent c'est évidemment pas le cas dans
toutes les filières c'est évidemment pas
le cas dans toutes les territoires mais
il faut pas se dire qu'être agriculteurs
c'est le bagne où que ce ne peut être
qu'une passion c'est bien une vocation
un métier qui a un sens
ce extraordinaire mais qui est aussi une
source de revenus laurent delorme je
sais que vous voulez intervenir depuis
un long moment voulaient intervenir par
rapport à l' on est toujours par
l'installation des jeunes et des jeunes
qui cherchent je te dit tout à l'heure
que on a eu du mal à trouver des jeunes
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à trouver des
jeunes et on a pourtant nous là la safer
on a on peut trouver à des jeunes qui
veulent s'installer on a des
investisseurs des gens des gens qui ont
encore de l'argent et qui veulent mettre
de l'argent dans le foncier est d'avoir
un jeune d'un jeune qui veut qui veut
reprendre les exploitations juste avec
le petit travail est payé un bail à la
fin d'année et on s'est pas c'est pas
dur ne retrouve pas non plus à tous les
coins de rue on n'en trouve pas tous les
coins de rue parce que c'est pas évident
parce que parce que peut-être qu'ils ont
peur parce que parce que il ya tout un
tas de choses qu'il est qu il leur dit
non il ya le côté administratif qui
charge qui me charge de travail
considérable
il ya le tout toutes les contraintes
environnementales
je comprends qu'il ya des besoins mais
mais qui sont aussi leur font peur je
pense que iliad et même s'il ya du monde
sur le marché même s'il y en a qui veut
dire oui je devrai bien être agriculteur
mais on n'en trouve pas on n'en trouve
pas tous les tout le temps comme ça
facilement et pourtant on peut leur
trouver là des moyens pour pour les
installer aussi c'est pour ça que je
voulais rebondir par rapport au monsieur
à qui il disait oui on en trouve au long
trou mais c'est pas un mec bizarre
venait de nous vanter les mérites chose
à votre façon tout à fait mais parce que
mais c'est très bien et maximy il veut
il veut qu'il du monde qu'est ce qu'ils
soient agriculteurs il je sais bien nous
aussi mais mais c'est pas et je le vois
je le vois autour de chez moi et
d'exploitation tout à l'heure en beauce
où les enfants veulent pas reprendre
donc il faut il faut retrouver leur d
exploitation de 200 300 hectares qui tue
personne veut reprendre donc il faut
quelqu'un qui ait les moyens de le
reprendre et acheter le foncier
la solution proposée par bernard
laffitte qui nous explique tout à
l'heure que sur une exploitation est
arrivé à diviser sa en trois petits
morceaux et installé trois personnes sur
une pourquoi on fait pas ça alors c'est
que ces quelques cas en région centre où
il ya des exploitants qui sont très
militant qui permettent à des jeunes de
s'installer dans des productions très
diversifiée par exemple j'ai quelques
cas où il des fois il ya un petit
élevage d'animal il ya une production
laitière du fromage de transformation
circuits courts ils ont boulanger on
voit des gens chose mais ça reste quand
même très marginale ça a beaucoup de
sens et je pense que la crise ait pas
qu'on vivra qu'on vient de vivre a fait
redécouvrir ce genre de choses il ya
beaucoup de gens qui livrait en abattant
secousses ont trouvé débordé il ya un an
mais parce qu'il n'avait plus la qu'ils
avaient pas la production pour
satisfaire vient donc effectivement mais
ça reste des signaux faibles je dirais
actuellement la coupe et la gauche en
italie c'est une solution vous défendez
absolument vicus oui on défend ce genre
de choses il faut des actions nombreuses
il faut essayer des petites fermes jédir
le grand risque aujourd'hui c'est ce que
évoqué maxime bizon vraiment le nom
c'est l'agrandissement as en face a
conduit l agriculture sans agriculteur
je dire on voit se développer et n'est
vraiment ce qu'on appelle le travail à
façon je dire l'exemple type c'est les
chinois mais il ya aussi plein d'autres
agriculteurs qui ont recours un sage qui
voudraient veut dire quoi ça daniel 300
acteurs c'est simple nous avait 75 ans
le préciser vous êtes toujours
exploitants agricoles vous avez un
téléphone et un bureau et vous avez une
entreprise de travaux agricoles qui va
faire tous les travaux et vous allez
vous allez de toucher des aides pac
vous allez rémunérer la lente reprise
qui viennent ponctuellement il en a à
dire et faire les travaux
alors ces entreprises là elle va pas
s'amuser à à bricoler sur une surface de
deux hectares
il faut arracher les il faut il faut la
placer le tout je dire donc on va faire
des systèmes très simplifié avoir
recours une façon massive aux intrants
la biodiversité c'est pas leur problème
donc et la vie du territoire c'est pas
leur problème non plus dire si c'est
plus de crèches y a plus d'école s'il ya
plus de services et plus de service
public c'est pas leur problème me dire
ça qu'on l'a très bien vu dans le film
ça conduit à un appauvrissement du
territoire en zone intermédiaire où il
n'y a pas d'autres productions où il pas
d'autres emplois c'est un véritable
désastre je viens lance un département
qui perd des habitants
chaque recensement c'est un vrai
problème je dire donc cet angle là ils
font sortir lire ils font à salima celle
des jeunes il faut il faut les aider et
il faudrait aussi que nos fils de nos
comparatifs et nos filières écoles
permettent pas ce que tout le pont tout
le monde ne prend pas tant circuits
courts il faut permettre l'émergence de
nouvelles filières non pas des citations
du marché mondial mais à destination du
marché européen part du marché local du
marché français voire du marché européen
jédir la destination de la production
agricole c'est d'abord pour nourrir les
locaux la france car un peu l'europe
parce qu'il ya certains pays d'europe
qui sont un petit peu dit viens de
trouver un sujet sur lequel on n'est pas
d'accord c'est que disait tout à l'heure
la chine 20% de la population 8 % des
terrains
si tous les pays se mettaient à arrêter
d'exporter à réserver leur production au
marché national je termine au marché
national
on aboutirait à une situation de blocage
comme on l'a connu sur des denrées
médical il ya pas très longtemps sur les
masques l'assureur axa on pourrait
aboutir la même situation sur le marché
des matières premières alimentaires
il ya je pense une discours honnête la
part des responsables agricoles avoir
sur ce qu'est l'agriculture régionale
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord une
agriculture qui approvisionne la france
c'est le grenier à grains de la france
même la région centre et qu'il faut en
être fier et c'est bien la première
vocation de la région centre que de
produire les matières premières
nationales s'est développée c'était déjà
le cas depuis très longtemps mais ses
revenus et sa se redévelopper et c'est
un extraordinaire coup de boost à
l'agriculture l'agriculture en circuit
court avec des maraîchers sur 2,5
hectares avec des petits élevages avec
l'abattage ou de la transformation sur
place et c'est très bien mais on a une
part de l'agriculture régionale qui vit
et qui doit continuer à vivre grâce à
l'exportation
je pense au sujet des blés durs ce qui
permet de faire les parades par exemple
rien qu'en région centre ont produit
plus que la consommation nationale de
blé dur c'est la même chose sur les
orges de brasserie on aller pour faire
la bière whisky on a les orges les plus
réputés au monde dans le gâtinais
ce sont des productions qui ramène de la
valeur ajoutée parce qu'elles ont un
une marge aurait dire une capacité une
valorisation sur le marché qui est bien
supérieur parce qu'on les exportent est
ce qu'on pourrait faire au niveau
national et donc il faut pas chercher à
simplifier les choses en disant à faire
que du circuit court que de la
production nationale que les sports
c'est bien l'ensemble de ces trois
agriculture la cie permet de maintenir
et de renforcer l'agriculture régionale
et son dynamique dans dynamise parlant
économique et social rapidement alors
rapidement l'exportation latika celui
que maxime busan comme présent
indispensable et créateur de hsc faut
dire la productivité par actifs hors
primes pac
ici en france est inférieur la
productivité aux primes pac du reste de
l'europe veut dire donc que les systèmes
de grandes cultures colza blé orge enfin
ses 70 ans grande culture 70% de la nsa
us et colza blé orge surface agricole
utile sau surface agricole utile 70%
colza blé l'orge le blé le blé de la
région centile c'est pas pour nous c'est
peut-être le grenier à blé de la france
mais c'est surtout pour le grand export
gémir donc vous vous dites y'a pas
besoin de recruter à ce point qu'on
focalisons nous sur ce qu'on a
sauvons nos fermes quand vous prenez les
surfaces qui existe en europe
et si on met deux frontières autour de
l'europe des 27 et quand on traduit en
surface tout les l'import-export je dire
l'europe importe des surfaces agricoles
pour nourrir sa population je dire
aujourd'hui donc le grand export il
n'est pas indispensable pour la
souveraineté alimentaire soit d'accord
effectivement la rive sud de la
méditerranée
elle a probablement besoin de céréales
mais des pays comme la chine par exemple
qui a besoin de céréales se sont marchés
s'inquiètent c'est pas l'europe c'est
plutôt l'australie pour raisons
politiques qui vont pas en australie
d'aujourd'hui mais dire que quand nous
en france on exporte énormément de
produits agricoles tels que l'orge et le
blé en chine par exemple la chine c'est
plus un client ça patron la chine achète
énormément d'enjeux chez nous je veux
dire si demain la chimie arrêtent
d'acheter de l'orge
en france on va mettre en très grande
difficulté nos producteurs ici en région
sans le dire on assistait mme boulet si
on arrête d'exporter de la même manière
si on arrête d'exporter on a des
surprises fenomeno aujourd'hui en france
je savais juste à tuer les agriculteurs
proches de la mère dira gare et ont
exporté je demande que les productions
agricoles soient poussés vers le
archi communautaire d'accord ça on est
bien d'accord qui est beaucoup plus
résilient par rapport aux différentes
crises qui peuvent dans le monde
un tout petit mot très rapidement va
rechercher nos amis qui sont en visio
bernard laffitte vous avez une minute
pour réagir à ce qui vient d'être
échangé sur ce plateau j'imagine que
vous percevez les choses de la même
manière que jm'en ou non oui tout à fait
un
est ce que je voulais dire c'est que de
toute façon effectivement on privilégie
pas uniquement les circuits courts il ya
tout à toutes les productions
c'est évident mais effectivement la
première chose à viser à mon sens c'est
quand même l'autonomie alimentaire de la
france noir l'autonomie alimentaire des
régions et éviter les importations g
prend comme exemple par exemple les
tomates qu'on est qu collaborent
énormément d'espagne où je vais prendre
le soja américain où les protéines qu'on
importe d'amérique d'accord donc c'est
ça qu'il faudrait éviter est plutôt
produire produire en france si on peut
donc chasser c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose sur laquelle je
voulais revenir effectivement tout à
l'heure j'ai utilisé le terme de 70 eur
70 ans c'était pour dire qu' il fallait
pas bercer de rêve et les années
essentielle aux millions mais sachant
que effectivement nous acteurs de liens
en général quand on a un porteur de
projet qui vient il passe dans ce qu'on
appelle un devant un comité régional
d'engagement et ensuite un comité
d'engagement national est la première
chose qu'on va regarder c'est le facteur
humain c'est-à-dire la cohérence sur
l'idéal est ce que ça va pas
déséquilibrer cette année est-ce que
humainement il peut assurer le travail
sans surcharge de travail et sans
risquer de berne où s'affairent première
chose qu'on va regarder la deuxième
chose qu'on va regarder c'est
l'insertion locale et ce qui les lie
avec type humain et s'y connaît les
agriculteurs du secteur
est ce qu'il a elle s'y tenait les
circuits courts et ce qu'il connaît les
âmes à es6 à des marchés et après aussi
très important on va regarder l'aspect
financier parce que il faut
effectivement que la personne est cuite
6 2
ou des centres avec merci beaucoup
bernard laffitte il faut absolument
qu'on aille chercher laurent delorme ce
sera le mot de la fin laurent vous avez
une trentaine de secondes pour réagir je
suis désolé l'émission se termine juste
après nous écoute moi je voulais juste
réagir par rapport à ce que disait marc
sigle sur les exportations y qu'on va
pas laisser mourir les africains si on a
de la note quoi les nourrir on va pas
laisser mourir les africains ça c'est la
première chose et fiction revient à
l'accaparement des terres en skiff
il faut que les pouvoirs publics nous
nous donne les moyens de pouvoir éviter
éviter ce ces sociétés qui secret et ne
parvenant pas à maîtriser et donc il
faut que les pouvoirs publics mettent
les moyens pour qu'on arrive au bout a
évité tout ce qu'apparemment et ben
merci beaucoup vous avez finalement
reparler d'accaparement on est revenus
au départ ça nous permet de boucler la
boucle
je vous remercie infiniment tous les
quatre d'abord été avec nous débattre au
cours j'en ai bien conscience
n'hésitez pas à revoir cette soirée
allez vous renseigner auprès de tous ses
interlocuteurs si vous voulez creuser le
sujet ça te ferait bien sûr elle est à
revoir sur votre site internet préféré
cv d'elle en france 3 point fr à très
bientôt pour un nouveau débat doc
[Musique]